wir gehen jetzt in den bundestag und
dort möchte ich ihnen tessa ganserer
vorstellen
bundestagsabgeordnete der grünen
tessa ganzer das ist sie nicht zu ihr
kommen wir gleich zeigt einmal tessa
gansera müssen wir sehen
bundestagsabgeordnete der grünen sie hat
eine ganz besondere geschichte sie hieß
früher hier sehen wir sie markus doch
dann vor drei jahren hat sie eben
bekannt gegeben als trans frau leben zu
wollen zu leben als tessa gansera und
damit ist sie eine schillernde
persönlichkeit im bundestag auch damit
und sie ist aber auch heftigen
anfeindungen ausgesetzt und jetzt kommen
sie kommen wir zu der frau die sie eben
schon gesehen haben zu beatrix von
storch nämlich einer frauen af der ein
die immer wieder ja polemisiert und
tabus brechen möchte die auch ganz
gezielt verletzt und das hat sie gestern
im bundestag gemacht ganz persönlich
verletzt tessa gansera mit dieser rede
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren frauen werden
abgeschafft sie fast alle hier sind
frauen abschaffen sie behaupten das
geschlecht hat mit biologie nichts zu
tun und jeder kann sich sein geschlecht
irgendwie selbst bestimmen da
selbstbestimmung gesetz kommt dann hier
demnächst auch in diesem theater die
gender ideologie gefährdet vor allem
frauen und mädchen männer brechen
rekorde im frauenschwimmen männer in der
damen- und kleide sexualverbrecher im
frauengefängnis weil sie sich gerade als
frauen fühlen wenn der kollege markus
ganserer rock lippenstift haken schuhe
trägt dann ist das völlig in ordnung es
ist aber seine privatsache biologisch
und touristisch ist und bleibt er ein
mann
weil sein beispiel uns so schön vor
augen führt dass es einen unterschied
macht ob man sich als frau verkleidet
oder ob man eine frau ist am
weltfrauentag ist ein guter moment um
festzustellen ein fisch es kein fahrrad
ein mann ist keine frau und gender ist
gaga
beatrix von storch die in diesem moment
der im plenum sitzenden tessa ganser
also dass frau sein abspricht daraufhin
gab es heftige reaktionen heftigen
beistand von ganz ganz vielen
bundestagsabgeordneten vor allen dingen
auf einer grünen fraktionsvorsitzenden
britta haßelmann die darauf hin dass
geantwortet hat
das was die abgeordnete storch sich
gerade in diesem haus erlaubt hat ist
niederträchtig
niederträchtig bodenlos ist es vor ort
und zutiefst menschenverachtend
aber dieses haus ist ein haus der
demokratie und der freien rede
und deshalb konnte sie das hier sagen es
erschüttert mich zutiefst
dass jemand über eine kollegin im
deutschen bundestag so abscheulich und
niederträchtig spricht besser ganze ist
eine von uns sie ist meine und unsere
kollegin sie ist eine der 59 prozent
anteil frauen in dieser fraktion
und niemand von uns hat darüber zu
richten oder
darüber zu reden oder zu entscheiden wie
diese frau ihr selbstbestimmungsrecht
wahrnimmt
wir sollten zusammenstehen bei aller
unterschiedlichkeit in der sache als
demokratische kräfte wenn einen solchen
menschenverachtung hier im haus passiert
stellen wir uns dem entgegen danke dafür
ein so emotionales
wortgefecht im bundestag eine
hochemotionale debatte nach persönlichen
anfeindungen gegen tessa gansera darüber
wollen wir hier im studio sprechen mit
der ersten transsexuellen bundeswehr
kommandeuren und auch aktivistin
anastasia biefang es bei uns schönen
guten tag bei bild live wir haben die
szene gerade noch mal gezeigt aus dem
bundestag ganz bewusst weil wir zeigen
wollten was dort gestern los war welche
anfeindungen es dort gab und aber auch
welche solidarisierung es aus weiten
teilen des bundestags daraufhin gab wir
haben diese sie diese szenen gestern
erlebt also abgesehen davon ist
schockiert waren wahnsinnig falle es
auch persönlich also herrscht
solidarität mit tessa gomber steht bei
twitter gerade überall rum und ich
glaube dass das wesentliche zeichen
dafür und ich bin auch froh als aktivist
sind auch als persönlicher als
transgender das nehmen nicht der hass
überwiegt sondern ist eine breite große
reaktion der unterstützung auf für tessa
gekommen ist das ist wichtig und das
zeigt eigentlich dass wir in dieser
gesellschaft deutlich weiter sind als
das gedankengut der zurückbleibenden afd
also sie können nach vorne schauen sie
wollen sich gar nicht auf das
konzentrieren weil es dort für hass
worte gefallen sind was möchten sie aber
doch auch dem entgegensetzen menschen
die so etwas sagen ich kann mir
vorstellen auch ihnen ist so etwas oft
begegnet und sie wissen ganz genau wie
sich auch besser kann sarah gefühlt hat
als diese worte sie trafen was wollen
sie dem entgegensetzen also ich kann
hingegen setzt einfach nur sichtbarkeit
für das thema sichtbarkeit dadurch dass
ich aktiv für unsere alle rechte
eintreten und auch entsprechend auf wie
es gesagt wurde dass wir einfach mal
weiter kommen dass wir das unsägliche
was pathologisiert transiente menschen
dieser gesellschaft und auch
stigmatisiert das transsexuellengesetz
von 180 was immer noch unseren weg
fremdbestimmt zu einem einen geschlecht
hin das ist endlich abgeschafft wird und
ich glaube in dieser legislaturperiode
mit der koalition die an der regierung
ist gerade haben wir die beste chance
endlich das selbst stimmungs gesetz
durch zu bekommen das wir auch als ich
befreit werden aus der fremdbestimmtheit
raus in ein selbstbestimmtes leben und
auch selbst bestimmt unser geschlecht an
zeigen können denn die einzige person
die über mein eigenes geschlecht
bestimmen und aussagefähig ist bin ich
und das wird es endlich geschafft
geschichten biografien wie ihre wie die
von tessa gansera die waren eben ganz
lange tabuisiert und deswegen gibt es
natürlich viele die berührungsängste
haben und auch sagen wie kann das
überhaupt sein möglicherweise auch bei
beatrix von storch würden sie sich mit
ihr auseinandersetzen darüber ich sag
mal eine man hat immer die möglichkeit
für eine offene kommunikation ob ich
mich mit frau von storch zusammensetzen
wollen würde nicht daran ob sie sich mit
mir zusammen setzen wollen würde ich
glaube er nicht bisher waren meine
anfragen bei fdp-abgeordneten sie mich
selber beleidigt haben er dann
zurückhaltend bis gar nicht mehr
antworten ich glaube möchte sie auch gar
nicht der diskussion stellen weil sie
einfach wissen dass die argumente
einfach nicht da sind es ist einfach nur
polemik die verletzend aber das wissen
von 2 und wir haben also versucht dort
auch mal einen dialog zu gehen wenn
ihnen selbst das passiert ist dann aber
gemerkt er wird gemauert und das war
bisher die reaktion von 12 mal wenn man
gesagt hat wir können uns immer treffen
darüber sprechen beim verlief das
meistens im sande klar im bundestag
gestern aber dieses thema das ist seit
langem auf der tagesordnung das setzen
sie ja auch auf die tagesordnung des
garten moment der ist ein paar monate
her hier im studio dabei helge braun bei
mir zu gast er war damals im rennen cdu
parteichef zu werden und ich habe ihm
diese frage gestellt
in der politik ist es gerade umstritten
wie viel geschlechter ist eigentlich
gibt wie viel gibt es dann
also ich glaube
dass es da gibt es dann eben neben den
klassischen auch dass diverse und
darunter subsummiert sich noch mal sehr
sehr viel also ich glaube nicht dass man
es abschließend zählen kann das zeigt
wie schwer es ist in dieser diskussion
auch klare antworten zu finden haben sie
auf diese frage nach der zahl der
geschlechter eine klare antwort ich
glaube es geht gar nicht um die zahlen
wieviel geschlechter essen gibt wenn wir
einfach verstehen würden das wären in
pohl männlich und im pool weiblich das
spektrum begreifen und tatsächlich die
eigene aussage des menschen wohl wir uns
verorten auf diesem spektrum sind das zu
akzeptieren und dann auch wertschätzen
diese menschen begegnen wir sehr viel
erreicht manchmal ist einfach
akzeptieren auch einfacher als verstehen
und wenn man etwas nicht erklären kann
dann sollten auch einigen einfachen
versuchen nur zu akzeptieren und das
wäre der erste schritt in richtung auch
gleichberechtigung und gleichstellung
herzlichen dank für ihren besuch hier
mit der spektakulären biographien
nämlich auch sie erste transsexuelle
bundeswehr kommandeuren so ist es glaube
ich ganz korrekt vielen dank für den
besuch unsere wertschätzung haben sie
vielen dank dann gesagt danke sehr